-I love it
when you guys are here.
Is this the first time you guys
have actually been on the show?
-No, we're always here.
They're always here.
-We're Robert's cheer squad.
-We love supporting Robert.
We love your show.
And I love the cheese wheel
in the green room
every time we come here.
It's awesome.
-Yeah. You do. Thank you, yeah.
-Actually, tomorrow
marks the second year
that Robert's been coming
on your show.
How exciting is that?
-Thank you, buddy.
♪♪
-And when he first came
on your show --
I actually posted a picture
of Robert and Dad
side-by-side
on "The Tonight Show."
I think you have the photo.
They're both holding a snake.
And it brought tears to my eyes.
It was so special.
Isn't that just amazing?
And Robert is more and more
like Dad every single day,
and we're so proud of him.
-And you're not at all like Jay.
-Yeah, I'm a little more scared
than Jay was, yeah.
-Maybe their expression
is slightly different.
-A little more frightened.
-We're very proud of you, too.
You've done so well
with all the animals.
-You guys are just
great for what you do.
I want to get into this.
Tell us about Wildlife Warriors.
What is it?
-Yeah, well, Wildlife Warriors,
it was started many years ago.
17 years ago, actually.
Mom and Dad first started it.
As a way to unite everyone
to stand up for those
that don't have a voice.
So it covers humanitarian
and wildlife issues
all over the world.
And since it's started, they
vowed to put every cent back in.
So whenever people donate,
everything that we make
goes straight back into there.
And it's protecting animals
all over the world,
and it's giving people
the chance
to really have a voice,
have their say.
In Australia, crocs have
now been really on the decline.
Their eggs are being taken
and harvested
to be turned into meat.
So we're really working hard
to really change the society's
perspective on conservation.
'Cause, ultimately,
it's about us, as well.
-Yeah. That's good for you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's great.
But, also, the animal hospital
part of the Australia Zoo
and what you do --
How many animals
have you treated?
-Over 82,000 animals.
-82,000.
-82,000. Yeah.
So, we opened in 2004.
And we rescue sick,
injured, orphaned animals
just to get them
back out into the wild.
And it's so special.
It's what we love.
-That's amazing.
And the money from the zoo,
some profits from there
go to the hospital?
-Yeah. Completely.
It's really exciting
when you visit Australia Zoo.
It's all about the wildlife.
It's hands on with everything.
And if you're walking with
a tiger or hugging a koala
or feeding a giraffe,
those experiences fund
all of the nonprofit activities
that we have around the world.
So it's really awesome.
Come to Australia Zoo.
You can go to
WildlifeWarriors.org
and sign the petition
to protect crocodiles.
And it's very special.
-You have some big news
about a giraffe.
-Oh, yeah.
-Yes. We do.
At Australia Zoo, we actually
have some very exciting news.
One of our giraffes is pregnant
and is going to be
giving birth very soon.
We're so excited.
And we wanted to give you the
chance to name this little baby.
I know you've selected
a couple names, and --
-I'm excited. Two names.
-Two names.
And then we'll let
all of you guys choose
which one's the best, and --
Yeah, it's coming very --
-Do we know if it's
a boy or girl?
-Not at this point.
You know, giraffes --
it's 15 months, the gestation
So it takes a long time
before that little one pops out.
So it's pretty amazing.
-I'm excited.
Thank you for giving me
this opportunity.
And thank you
for coming on the show.
And thank you for everything
you're doing for animals
around the world and everything.
We love you, guys, so much.
-We love you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you so much.
-Terri, Bindi, and Robert Irwin.
Visit WildlifeWarriors.org
for details on
how to get involved.